hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the first installment of
reading your comments ba boo boo boo
para b op b ba p but I hope we how's my
theme song ultra qex condone a says hey
mark maybe you could organize your
friends to make an unboxing video
together I mean yeah I'll gifts are for
you but together you should have the
required time to get through everything
and have fun together
works for me but I'd rather keep those
things kind of personal you know it's
presents for me not that I just don't
want to share the glorious is it people
gave it to me it's my responsibility to
open them and check them all out so
that's what I do tiny box Tim asks mark
you seriously need to stop being cute
because my heart can't take it you're in
guys no more being cute
they'll be adorable serious crystal
feather and multiply from now on
mark is the nicest person ever where are
the others going mark can you stop being
so awesome and generous and I sacrificed
enough as I give more of my soul to the
city survival tailor Lillian Hubble asks
I'm sure my comments gonna get lost in
here but I was wondering mark have you
ever become friends with fans that
you've met before and if so were they
veteran friends of yours like me or more
recent fans now it is hard because the
way it's set up I don't get a chance to
actually hang out with people and become
friends with them because I consider
close friends people that I hang out on
a regular basis with and the way I go to
conventions only able to meet people for
like a few minutes at a time and then I
go back home hundreds or thousands of
miles away it's really difficult that
being said there are rare occasions
where I am able to meet someone that's
really cool who is a fan of mine there's
this guy by the name of Jonathan Hicks
at Hickey Dundee on twitter i think who
i met three years ago at comic-con and
he said like came up to me he was like
I'm your biggest fan period I can't
believe a meeting I thought he was a
really cool guy so every year since then
we've been meeting up at comic-con this
last time we even got dinner with some
of his friends and he's in the military
I believe the Navy and he was out on
deployment and he wasn't even able to
watch my videos for a while but we keep
up fairly semi-regularly on twitter so
he's a cool dude so it's rare but it
does happen it's just like the
circumstances for which it could happen
don't come up that often lord vader 1094
reading your comments with mark oh joy
will be able to connect with mark so
much more now with him answering
questions from fans just like with Shaun
series over on JSC actually I talked to
Jack about that or about that while I
was at PAX I said I wanted another way
to really engage with you guys and he
kind of said that you know I've told him
I wanted to do as he's just said just do
it you know how Jack talks that's my
impression yes and so I did if we keep
giving mark tiny box
Tim's he'd be able to build a house of
his own filth floor to ceiling with
inhale my dong pillows and small
bleeding sheep trapped under layers of
pillows maybe a pet draft - I don't know
assertive dong inhale Minh
house of horrors you're coming up with
but this is a weird zoo I want to know
apartment plus I don't want to pet
giraffe you'd make me feel inferior for
sure what did your dad look like wolf
Jedi Samuel asked if they made a movie
about your life who would you like to
play you in the film who would you like
to play as tiny box Tim well no I don't
want a movie about my life but if
someone was gonna play me I would want
to be Joseph gordon-levitt and then I
would want to be able to meet Joseph
gordon-levitt and then hang out with him
because he's really cool and tiny box
him would be played by Danny DeVito
2012 sandokan hey hi mark how do you
feel when you realize there are still
people like me that have been following
you since your beard was not growing yet
and that little shark fin style was
rocking all the action in your videos it
honestly feels great I mean I I know for
a fact that there are many really loyal
long-term fans that are stuck with me
for a long time and honestly it's
humbling the fact that over time you
know I'm not saying like I've changed so
much but my style has kind of evolved
and I've become more confident in what
I'm doing and I'm always trying new
things
it always is warming to me to know that
people stick with me even though I'm
always doing new things and I'm trying
new things and I'm establishing new
styles and I'm getting weird sometimes
like really really weird looking at you
markiplier walks down the street no
khazana come on ask what if the monster
you keep summoning behind us is really
behind you well the next time you open
your closet door this is all that's
gonna be staring back from the darkness
[Applause]
seelix gaming what has been your
favorite new thing you've done or tried
in the past couple months this year to
be honest it's music you know I I love
music but I don't really listen to bands
that much and I don't have a favorite
band but I started taking singing
lessons this year and I played trumpet
for six years in high school so I
already had a good basis for music
I understood music theory and I had an
ear for music but taking singing lessons
has really opened up a lot of new
territory for me and gets me excited
about the idea of taking the music
that's in my head that I hear all the
time and that I create in my mind and
being able to put it onto something
tangible that other people can listen to
like that creative process is really
inspiring for me miyuki-chan
I wanted to know of you have any
personal insecurities you don't have to
go deep into the answer okay love yeah
that's not really a question that you
can't answer deeply I mean as far as my
own personal insecurities go I've
actually managed to conquer a lot of
them by doing YouTube you know I used to
not be as self confident as I am now it
was kind of a fake it till you make it
kind of deal where I just was born
basically I'm the best look at how
strong I am and now I'm just like I'm
pretty amazing you know pretty cool
right and then I hang around my friends
and they just knocked me right back down
but personal insecurities I would say
that I have a strong fear of failure I
mean a lot of people do but it's not
really the fear of failure that I'm
crippled and I'm like oh my gosh I
really don't hope that I fail it's more
like oh gosh I really want to push
myself to do something great like even
though I fail I I don't mind failing
it's just that I don't want to
disappoint people like I I don't want
people to look at what I've done be like
oh that's just typical boring bull I
want them to look at what I do and be
like so it was amazing how did you do
that or that was weird why did you do
that like those are the things that I
want and I have a really weird
insecurity about the idea that people
will look at what I do and think it's
just ordinary I want to do something
extraordinary I want to do something
amazing that really makes people go what
was it like being on Jimmy Kimmel Live
that's about all I can say about I enjoy
your shortness ain't joint your dumbness
darkened auras do you ever think you'll
play a part in a full-length horror
movie to be honest I would rather not
play a part I would rather make a horror
movie because something that means the
cynical guys talked about that we know
horror pretty well and we're always
disappointed when we go to movies and we
see these horror movies and they're just
filled with cliches and they don't have
interesting ideas they're not set up
well even like the soundtracks are just
boring cliched bull like we know in our
hearts that we could probably make a
horror movie and with that something
we've actually talked about we've talked
about like making a short that could
show people what we could do as far as
like making a really scary experience so
maybe that's something you'll see in the
future Marc I speak for all of us when I
say that you are nothing short of
amazing is that a short jump from your
wacky humor to your charitable heart
there's really not a bad thing about you
that we get to see at least winky face
I mean that really means a lot to me I
mean I try to put myself as much as
possible onto the screen like the real
true me I try to show you guys what I
really think of what I really feel in in
the best light possible of course but I
try to show you guys Who I am on an
individual level because that's
something that I believe is very
important about these things and one of
the reasons why I want to be reading
your comment series is because I want to
be able to interact with you guys I want
you guys to know me for who I am and
then make a judgement based off of that
I don't want to put forward like my best
image and then be like the zoo I I want
to like show you guys that I'm a real
human being because that's what we all
are and that's what people really make
connections to I don't want to be this
ethereal guy on a pedestal either I
don't want to be like oh my god he's so
amazing and famously I don't want that
that seems like the opposite of
everything that I stand for like I I
want you guys to be of the mind that you
could as just as easily be in my
position you could just as easily be in
my shoes I'm just someone that works
hard to show you guys who I really am
that's all mark will you marry me No
freddy fazbear says I was expecting you
to do the unboxing video without any
pants on little disconcerting that
Freddy fazbear was expecting me not wear
pants says a little bit about our
relationship
markable are you actually four foot
seven feet high bro hey Jax the boss
you're the loser because you failed your
own quiz hahahahaha even throw your
stupid not really bro how do you learn
to get over certain things that may
scare you while playing video games it's
often hard for me to handle jump scares
without running into my room at the
speed of light because suspense thank
you
honestly I like being scared I like the
adrenaline rush it gives but if you can
actually run at the speed of light which
is the more important part of this
question don't
you'd kill all of us what is your next
reaction compilation those are some of
my favorite videos bye you very soon
actually now that I have an editor by
the name of Matt by the way I can
actually free up some time to work on
cool stuff like more reaction
compilations because it used to be that
I had to record and it upload do all the
metadata make the thumbnails all by
myself which left no time for activities
free time socializing in addition to
other cool editing that I can do and
I've got all these editing skills
look.we I'm two or three days late so
poop are you talking about pregnancy or
constipation because one of those things
really bad and the other is constipation
ha ha ha how come you don't have a
separate channel for your gaming
[Music]
markipliergame I just have a philosophy
that it's my channel because it's me so
whatever I do I put on the same channel
because people come for whatever the
hell I'm going to do which could be
literally anything at any time for any
reason
silly face silly face silly face silly
face hashtag derpy me happy face +
markiplier markiplier hey Marga bar
guess what smirks I has a mustache but
is blue kitty face also I've messed up
brain cuz no fast jump scares are scary
I just go from your half 1-4 jump scares
Han just face goes way close to screen
within 5m scares my family screams one
day
screams sad face bro for when I'm eating
I eat like a pig man awesome man bear
Pig are you still selling the markiplier
PJs
very soon we'll have more police ready
for everybody to buy for another charity
stream we're actually are gonna be
making pj pants again because they're
really comfortable and I wear mine every
day but now they have hole in the crotch
for totally not the reason you're
thinking of unless you were thinking
what do you enjoy drop-kicking Nan's
down a flight of stairs on a pogo stick
so is the flight of stairs on the pogo
stick what do you think you would be
doing if you never started a YouTube
channel I could have been an engineer
mark you should do the bean boozled
challenge maybe with a special guest
even like the game ROVs
why didn't you accept Jack's proposal
because he wasn't good enough for me all
this - good
I meant video not episode sorry I don't
know what were yelling about so you're
quitting YouTube
noises hi mark I'm the creator of a
late-night drinking I'm working on a
sequel also planning to do a soma custom
story as well my question is if you
would be okay with me using the sound
clip from one of your videos as a sort
of Easter Egg in one of my custom
stories absolutely yes if if people
didn't know already a late-night drink
is actually the custom story where I
found tiny box Tim for the first time
you can check out that animation and the
playlist for the game down the
description below mark an introvert know
yeah you know you don't have to be an
extrovert just because you are
comfortable in public situations you're
comfortable public speaking I'm an
introvert because I enjoy my time the
most when I'm by myself and able to do
things on my own I like going to movies
by myself I like going to restaurants by
myself I like shopping by myself I like
playing games by myself I like doing
everything and it doesn't mean that I
don't like hanging out with friends it's
just that I'm comfortable being in the
public eye but I like to recharge by
myself and relax and get to know myself
what is your main reason for donating so
much to charity and helping the
community I'm very very lucky in what I
get to do and I'm very fortunate but
unfortunately there's millions upon
millions of people who aren't as lucky
as I am or aren't even nearly as lucky
as I am therefore I want to help balance
the equation and my personal philosophy
is that if everyone gave just a little
more than they took then the whole
community would benefit as a whole
a whole community that wholly benefits
coal tomorrow all I want in life is to
hear mark sing a cover of hallelujah for
some reason I have this feeling it would
be the most beautiful thing ever
well LP Dark Souls HD your wish is about
to be granted so that was the end of the
first episode of reading your comments I
really hope you enjoy this one I had a
ton of fun if you did and want to see
more leave another comment for me to
read down the comment section below and
thanks again everybody for joining me
thank you everyone that I read here and
thank you everyone who left a comment
that I didn't get to in the last video
thanks again everybody and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]